Fans sharing video reactions to movies, TV, and trailers.
And be sure to stay tuned until the end of the video to see how you can be on next week's Nostalgia Critic.
Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to.
Let's talk about the first Super Mario Bros. movie.
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Believe it or not, there was a Super Mario Bros. movie before that one.
And believe it or not, it starred actual brothers, a dragon, took place in the Mushroom Kingdom, and looked exactly like the game.
Audience: BOOOOO!
NC: I know, I know. I think it's weird for an adaptation to be faithful, too.
But this one is still interesting, to say the least.
In 1986, Japan released an animated movie called Super Mario Bros.: The Great Mission to Save Princess Peach.
Phht, silly Japanese, we Americans know it's Princess Toadstool.
It wasn't given a release in America because, you know, we were working on our own superior version,
but it has started to gain attention as being technically the first movie based on a video game.
Unless you count Apocalypse Now as an adaptation of Pong.
Most don't.
To make things a little easier to follow, I'm gonna look at the English dub on the YouTube channel Chad Kyer.
Mostly because it's the only one I could find and it does manage to get a laugh out of me.
Is the movie worth checking out?
Or, at least, more checking out than:
King Koopa: Monkey!
NC: Well, let's take a look and see.
Spoilers, it is.
This is Super Mario Bros.: The Great Mission to Save Princess Peach.
So it opens with Mario...
playing a video game.
Isn't that kinda like a sunflower painting van Gogh?
His brother Luigi, living presumably a Bert and Ernie lifestyle of sin,
tries to get him to quit, but he's just too addicted.
However, something strange starts to happen as the game starts to show a princess literally fighting off baddies with a stick.
The Royal Swingstick.
Hey, it's less sexist than a frying pan and her butt.
She magically comes out of the TV along with a bunch of dust smoke creating minions,
and...
they vanish.
Apparently, they're allergic to blue living rooms.
Hey, you laugh, but I'm prepared for the Koopapocalypse!
The princess wakes up and reveals herself as Peach.
Peach: Thanks for protecting me. My name is Princess Peach.
Mario: Princess Peach?
Peach: I believe you're Mario, the brave knight.
NC: As foretold in the scripture of the instruction book.
She tells him about King Koopa as well, who seems to follow her from the game.
I'm just gonna take a guess and say this runs on Space Jam logic.
That is to say none.
Peach: Beat him up, Mario! Make him pay for what he did!
NC: But I'm always the worst player!
Luigi can jump high, Toad can run fast, you can even fly!
He proves to be exactly that useless as he's easily defeated and Koopa takes Peach.
Luigi laughs at his story in his Italian Southern accent...
Luigi: What are you talking about? Princess asked you for help?
NC: C'mon, don't act like that's not a thing.
And they get to their job the following day as plumb-
Grocery store clerks.
Is there an unwritten rule that in every Mario movie, at least one obvious thing has to be wrong?!
Luigi sees the necklace Peach left behind and crams a lot of game exposition in only a few seconds.
Luigi: This gem has been passed on by the Kinopi people! It's worth fortunes!
Mario: Kinopi people?
Luigi: Yeah! See? Look right there!
This gem originates from the lost Mushroom Kingdom.
Borat: Is nice!
Luigi: Amazing!
Mario: Yeah!
Luigi: Let's go!
Luigi: Where's it at?
Mario: I don't know!
Hey, let's call our friend to find out.
Hello?
NC: Wow, I thought the flower shop scene from The Room was rushed and awkward.
But a strange caterpillar dog walks in and steals the necklace.
Mario: Hey, wait!
Hey, you, get back here!
NC: By the way, where is this again?
Do the Japanese think America is just one giant Road Runner background?
Because it's NOT!
It's mainly these 2 things.
They come across a series of pipes, but once they go down one, the rest of them disappear because you're high.
Mario and Luigi: Whooooooooa!
Oof!
NC: They arrive in the Mushroom Kingdom, as Gandalf's shower-drained pubic hair tells them.
Kinoko: Welcome, Mario Bros. The one that summoned you to the Mushroom Kingdom was none other than me.
NC: I'm as excited as Batman's Batcave announcer.
Batcave Announcer: Attention, attention! Family thinks high toy price is a joke!
NC: No, maybe not that excited.
He tells them how Peach turned down Koopa's wedding proposal, causing him to attack their fair Smurf village.
Kinoko: The evil King Koopa casted a spell on the Mushroom Kingdom, turning the citizens into blocks and stones.
NC: Wow, so Mario's kinda been committing mass genocide.